hello everybody i am back for another
video and today is going to be about
mongodb i've got probably about 15
minutes to record before my roommate
comes back and catches me in the process
that being said 15 minutes is a lot for
me because typically it takes me about
30 seconds to get finished in most
aspects of my life
so with that being said let's talk about
mongodb sorry i probably should have
made this video a while ago but i kept
like looking at and being like i
don't understand why this deserves a
video so in some senses it doesn't but
it seems that a lot of companies still
use it and for that reason i'm going to
talk about why they might do that okay
mongodb what is it well basically
mongodb is another nosql database but
this time as opposed to a bunch of the
other ones that i've talked about
mongodb actually uses a document
oriented format which basically means
that we've got collection of documents
and data can be stored within those
documents
it definitely has some pretty stark
differences to something like either a
relational database management system
and also on the other end of the
spectrum something like cassandra where
it kind of takes aspects of both and and
it really seems to position itself in
like a major middle ground between all
of the databases that we've covered so
far so i'm going to kind of describe the
architectural choices that have gone
into mongodb that makes it kind of work
that way and ultimately why it kind of
acts as a jack of all trades type of
database where its biggest utility is
probably the fact that the lack of
constraints on the type of operations
you can do on the data means that you
don't have to worry too much about
future maintainability you can kind of
just throw your data in mongodb and know
that the majority of your functionality
is probably going to be supported albeit
maybe not at the fastest possible speeds
okay so firstly let's talk about the
data format like i mentioned mongodb
stores its data in documents where
documents are stored in collections each
document can also have collections
within it and then you can have sub
documents within those collections so as
you can see i've put some of my favorite
actresses below and we've got videos
which are a sub collection which i
didn't really bother to picture but
you know the point is you can have other
video documents in each of those sub
collections what that does is it greatly
increases data locality you can store a
ton of information within these one
document
or within this one document and as a
result of that
you know if you need to access a ton of
stuff unlike a relational database
system where you know you may have to
perform a join
you can actually just get all of that
data in the same spot on disk
additionally do note that um the
documents don't necessarily have a set
schema even if i made it look that way
right here for example i could
definitely put other properties for each
of these documents that are unique like
i don't know maybe if i knew one of
their heights i could put the height
there or their weight or something along
those lines but the point is that
being able to not have
a set in stone schema is very useful for
mongodb because for developers who know
that their application and the data that
they're going to use is going to kind of
evolve over time having that flexible
schema allows you to have some peace of
mind that you're not going to have to do
a major migration downline or ever have
downtime or anything like that
okay so in terms of the architectural
overview i'm kind of just going to
breeze through this because we know what
most of these topics are at this point
and the point of this video for me
personally is not to you know kind of
discuss the inner workings of mongodb
but probably more so get to the bottom
of why you have so many people using it
and i'll i guess express my thesis
towards the end
so anyways obviously mongodb can store a
ton of data so within a collection if
you have a ton of documents you're
probably going to have to partition them
and you can do so by using something
called a shard key where manga will auto
generate this for you if you don't
specify it
it's basically just like the id of the
document and that way it allows you to
kind of express which document should go
on the same partition which gives you
some control over
you know the locality of certain
documents and maybe being able to access
them in something like a range query
and then within each chart you can use a
single leader replication
in these replication zones where you
have all of these followers that are
asynchronously getting changes from the
single leader and if the leader were to
go down then the followers will go ahead
and elect a new leader
it's important to note though that
generally speaking mongodb actually only
performs the reads from the leader so if
the leader does go down you may have a
few seconds of downtime you can actually
configure mongodb to not do that and
just allow some stale reads from
replicas in order to ever avoid that
downtime though
additionally as opposed to something
like cassandra which uses an lsm tree
based storage engine mongodb has chosen
to stick with the traditional b tree and
that means that reeds are going to be
prioritized a little bit over writes so
that's kind of more comparable to the
traditional relational database setup
additionally one cool thing that mongodb
lets you actually do unlike cassandra
is cross-partition operations so this is
where you get a little bit more freedom
than kind of cassandra's constrained
model of everything needs to go on one
partition and let's keep it there so
enables multi-document
transactions which means you can make
sure that multiple documents are either
all atomically edited or you know not
changed and that can either happen on
the same or different charts which is
you know it's a nice functionality even
if it's not the most efficient thing
additionally you can have parallelized
second uh you know secondary indexes and
big queries over the entire data set not
just one shard like cassandra
and these powerful secondary indexes
allow you to have a ton of flexibility
within mongodb to make queries as your
data evolves over time so you know as
far as cassandra goes you generally have
to really plan out how you're going to
be using that database beforehand to
make sure that your data is organized in
a way that all of your operations are
staying with on one shard
on the other hand with like i keep
trying to mention you have a lot more
flexibility to kind of dump your data in
there and maybe it won't be the most
efficient query but if you do need to
get the data somehow you can via all
these types of secondary indexes
okay so now let's actually do a quick
comparison because like i've mentioned
is definitely different than
relational databases in the sense that
you use a document data model which
allows for not only a flexible schema
but also much greater data locality if
you want to store a bunch of individual
records with one document
that means you can basically just have a
many-to-one relationship and as opposed
to running a join over
possibly many nodes and a network
connection you can just have those
stored all together that being said the
fact that this is a nosql database means
that data can be denormalized if you
choose to do that and then in that event
if you're going to make updates to
certain data you may have to make
multiple updates and it's probably the
case that you want to do those
atomically or else you may have data
inconsistencies
compared to something like cassandra
mongodb definitely has disadvantages and
disadvantages
the biggest advantage is probably
actually the data document model itself
um
although i should note that you know if
you're smart about kind of the design of
your clustering keys and cassandra you
can effectively just create your own sub
documents and cassandra by you know
using a clustering key that has like a
prefix with a uuid for any given row and
that way you can have them stored all
adjacently next to one another
additionally the fact that you can
perform more complicated queries not
just on one partition but over many
gives you a lot more flexibility within
your database to make sure that you
don't necessarily have to have
everything figured out when you're first
modeling out your data you know if it
happens to be the case that you know at
first that cassandra model seemed great
but then you realize you have some
associations in your data that you want
to be joining together then cassandra
becomes really infeasible and you
probably have to switch to an entirely
different database on the other hand
gives you that flexibility to kind
of dynamically create queries as you go
and through the lifestyle the life cycle
of your application and as a result like
i said it just gives the developer more
flexibility and the ability to keep the
application more maintainable
additionally that b tree architecture
unlike
what cassandra uses with ss tables and
bloom filters b-trees is a little bit
better for performing reads
on the contrary as you can see in red
but the fact that um mongodb
uses a b-tree architra architecture and
the fact that it uses single leader
replication makes rights pretty
significantly slower as opposed to
cassandra
that being said you know if you kind of
need the extra flexibility that
cassandra can't really provide you
you should probably go with mongodb
um so here's kind of my conclusion is
that
obviously when i was looking at
mongodb's website and i just know from
my own programming experience mongodb is
an extremely popular database solution
that being said it seems that the reason
for this is the fact that it's kind of
this nice middle ground between
relational databases which are great for
keeping data normalized and consistent
and you know
something like a multi-master leaderless
database like cassandra which is super
optimized for performance and right
throughput but only with a very specific
data access pattern in the case of
cassandra it's kind of just over one
shard
however what mongodb allows you to do as
a developer at least in practice is to
be able to kind of you know model the
data how you want but know that if you
ever need to fall back on you know
having to make a more inefficient query
using something like um you know
local secondary indexes and then kind of
combining those together in parallel you
can do that so you have this kind of
greater set of functionality
that being said as far as for systems
design interviews i can't imagine that
for the most part mongodb is going to be
the best answer to ever give that's
because in systems design interviews
you're not thinking about the
maintainability of the application as
much as you are how to solve a problem
at a given level of scale right in every
single systems design interview your
interviewer is going to say this is how
many users you have not this is how many
users you have now and you know in the
future expect this to double or at least
in my experience that hasn't been the
case maybe it can be
but the point is assuming that you're
just tackling one problem in the systems
design interview typically there's
probably going to be a more specialized
database solution that's going to work
better than mongodb
that being said though in practice you
know if you're trying to get an
application off the ground and you know
that you're going to be growing over
time the scalability and advanced
feature set of mongodb does make it very
useful so i hope that this video was a
nice introduction to document databases
i'll probably cover one more which i
think is going to be couch base and then
also one or two more new sql databases
and then we can